- Hi, everyone.
Welcome, you all,
to our monthly Nature of
Inference colloquium series.
As you all know, this is a new series
that we have started
at the Franke Program,
motivated by a lot of my own work.
Those of you who don't know
me, I'm Priya Natarajan.
I am an astrophysicist,
and I happen to be the current director
of the Franke Program in
Science and the Humanities,
at Yale.
My own work is, has been
in trying to understand
the phenomenology of black
holes in the universe,
and a persistent issue,
that has nagged all the modeling
and conceptual work I do,
is, whether the correlations,
empirical correlations,
that we actually see between
properties of black holes,
and the galaxies that
host them, and so on,
whether they actually
reflect a causal physics,
or are they just happenstance,
a consequence of some kind
of statistical manifestation
of the evolution of structure formation.
So that, sort of, seeded this interest,
but I've been so fortunate
that, as part of the series,
we have invited
very distinguished researchers
across disciplines,
who are working on
understanding the complex issues
of causal inference.
Focusing on how we draw robust conclusions
from conceptual models, and simulations.
So, the series represents
cutting-edge researchers,
who are exploring various
kinds of conceptual frameworks,
agent simulations,
ab initio time-evolution modeling
of complex nonlinear systems,
propagation of genetic
transcription and expression,
climate-modeling,
to distill the role that
modeling actually plays
in helping disentangle
correlation and causation.
And so we are getting this,
we're gonna to get this
multi-disciplinary view,
of how this is done.
It's a very challenging problem,
and it's a very fundamental
problem in epistemology,
across intellectual disciplines,
this distinction between
causation and correlation.
So, first let me thank-
Mr.
and Mrs. Richard and Barbara Franke,
for the generous support
of the Franke Program,
and all the other activities at Yale
that they have supported.
They plan to join us, today, for our talk.
And I also just want to remind you
that we are recording this event,
so I would request you
all to mute your videos,
and as for questions, after
this afternoon's talk,
we would like you to submit
them through the chat feature,
and-
either I,
..
or-
professor...
We don't expect professor
Ay to be watching the chat,
so it would be either Dr. Kamp or I,
who would be reading
out the chat questions,
and our format will be as per usual,
after his talk, we'll
have a Q&A afterwards.
I also want to remind you,
that a part of the series,
we have a follow-up
detailed discussion and Q&A,
the following day after the talk,
and Professor Ay has kindly
agreed to do that tomorrow,
again, at the same time, 3:00 pm.
That will be a conversation between him,
and Professor Kyle Cranmer,
who is a physicist,
who is working also on
applications of machine-learning
and AI techniques, to big data in physics.
So, really looking forward
to that exciting conversation as well.
So let me first introduce our
distinguished speaker today.
Professor Ay is an honorary professor
at the Max Planck Institute
for Mathematics in the
Sciences, at Leipzig,
and has a joint appointment
at the Santa Fe Institute.
He studied mathematics and
physics at Ruhr University,
and received his PhD from
the University of Leipzig.
In 2003 and 4, he was
a postdoctoral fellow
at the Santa Fe Institute,
and at the Redwood Neuroscience Institute,
which is at Berkeley.
After his post-doctoral time in the US,
he became
an assistant professor at
the Mathematical Institute
at the Friedrich Alexander
University in Erlangen,
and since September, 2005,
he's been a group leader
at the Max Planck Institute for
Mathematics in the Sciences,
where he's currently heading the group
on Information Theory
of Cognitive Systems.
As a professor of Santa Fe Institute,
he's involved in research on complexity
and robustness theory,
and-
since December 13,
he also has an Honorary Professor
of Information Geometry,
that's a very intriguing
title, at Leipzig.
He looks like he's going to
actually be moving very soon,
to the Hamburg University of Technology,
where he's going to be spearheading
and building up an entirely new institute,
the Institute of Data Science Foundations,
as part of their technology
and innovation center,
for Hamburg.
So, Professor Ay today
will start by providing us
an introduction to the
field of causal networks,
and will then focus on giving
us some simple examples
to drive home and highlight
the core conceptual and
philosophical ideas,
that underlie this theory.
He has a very novel approach,
that will show us how
this, kind of, new language
that he has developed
that will allow us to
distinguish between causation
and correlation.
He's also going to teach us
that this allows us to study
how cause and effect
relations will give rise
to a very particular kind of correlations,
and they can be exploited
to infer causal relations, in turn,
from the observed correlation.
So, you can imagine that
I am particularly excited,
because I think it's going
to be very, very relevant
for my own personal research agenda,
but I'm sure that you will all be excited
to hear and learn from him today.
So without further ado,
Nihat, I would like to
invite you to start.
Thank you so much for agreeing
to speak in our series.
- Yeah. Thank all much for inviting me,
and giving me this opportunity.
Let me-
share my screen.
So, thank you again.
As I-
wrote in one of my emails,
my presentation is going to
be a little bit technical,
but my-
intention is, actually,
to highlight the core-structures
of causal networks,
and the main philosophical
reasoning there.
I want to make the point,
as an introduction, I
want to make this point,
how far we can get, actually,
with a mathematical, formal structure of-
causation.
This is the outline of my presentation,
I know I'm not going to have enough time
to go through all these
subjects in detail,
but I think I will try to
communicate the main points.
Let's start with the causal,
with the structure of causal networks.
So the main building-block
of a causal network,
is the notion of a mechanism.
And the mechanism is-
basically, the idea is
that you have a function,
so it's mathematical
object, f of X, Y is f of X,
and then you allow for
disturbances of that function.
So, this is the disturbance, U.
Often, you have a model
where Y equals f of X,
plus some disturbance,
so that would be some
kind of additive noise,
it can be multiplicative noise,
but this version of it
is much more general,
so the function itself
depends on the input, X,
and the disturbance, U.
So that's the most general
way to write down a-
a mechanism, a deterministic mechanism.
That actually has been already
considered in genetics,
and in econometrics, social sciences,
information theory, and so on.
So, the idea is, that the disturbance,
it's actually not observable,
so what you observe is the X and Y.
So let me, okay.
Basically, you integrate
out the disturbance,
and as outcome Y,
you get a distribution of points.
For each point here is
generated by one disturbance,
small u.
So if you integrate out
this, the disturbance u,
you get for each input
X, a distribution of Y's.
Formally, this, after
integrating out the disturbance,
you get a mathematical object
that is called a Markov kernel.
Sometimes you call it stochastic
matrix, or stochastic map.
So the basic requirement here,
is that for each X, you have
a distribution on the Y's.
That's all.
So, it means that Kappa of XY
is greater than or equal to 0,
because that's the probability,
and the sum over the Y's,
or the integral over the Y's, should be 1.
That's all.
So that's the definition of a Markov,
of a so-called Markov kernel,
and that's the basic object,
basic mathematical object that is used
in order to model the mechanism.
The mechanism in the
context of causal networks,
is given in terms of a Markov
kernel, or stochastic map.
As I said, this has been
used in many contexts,
and with the same, you can do
the same construction here,
in the context of,
of quantum mechanics,
and there you end up
with the so-called
completely positive map,
which is frequently used in
quantum information theory.
So that's the building block.
Now, the question is, how to
put together these mechanisms?
The structure that describes
how to combine these mechanisms
is a Directed-
Acyclic-
Graph,
so, basically, it's-
as shown here.
So you have the nodes, these
are the variables, A, B, C, U.
U is not the disturbance,
here, it's one variable.
Basically,
the semantics here,
is whenever you have an arrow,
for example, from A to B,
A is the direct cause of B.
B is the effect, direct effect of A,
and you also require
that the cause always comes-
before the effect, okay?
That was the subject of
the previous presentation.
So, the,
the order has to be first the
cause, and then the effect.
That excludes cycles like this,
this is the reason why we have to assume
that-
the underlying structure is given
in terms of a directed acyclic graph.
So, some people actually
question this assumption, here,
but it's crucial.
So,
we have, in the context of...
Once given such a graph,
you can talk about the
parents of a node V,
denoted by pa,
which are simply those
nodes that point to V,
then the descendants of U,
these are those nodes that can be reached,
from U,
the non-descendants, and the ancestors.
So, basically, it's clear
from the naming, here,
what it means.
So, now, we have the graphical structure.
In my first slide, I explained
what we mean by a mechanism.
Now we have to put these
two structures together,
so we-
we start with a directed acyclic graph,
that's the structure,
and then we,
we assume that, for each node,
we have given such a Markov kernel,
a mechanism, which, basically,
is nothing than a stochastic map.
So it takes the inputs,
for example, in X4, here,
that node takes these as inputs,
and generates a distribution over X4.
So you have a mechanism in all nodes here.
The only-
node that does not get any input is X1,
so that's simply a probability
distribution over X1,
but all the others have mechanisms,
sitting-
in them.
As I explained, whenever we
have a directed arrow here,
we refer to v as being
the direct cause of w,
and w being the direct cause of v
and if I have such,
this curly-
arrow, that means that
there's a path from v to w.
so in that case, I simply
talk about cause and effect,
without-
referring to,
to it being directed, a direct cause.
So, this is a simple example,
taken from Judea Pearl's book,
it's quite a famous book here,
where the foundations of
cause networks are developed,
and so I'm not going to,
into the details here,
but with these,
this kind of Bayesian network,
you can actually describe
a causal structure,
or causal interaction of variables.
So this is a more complicate-
these are more complicated networks,
than the previous ones,
which are more like toy examples,
and these networks are taken
from, also a famous book,
by leading experts of the field,
by Lauritzen, and David,
who were-
and Spiegelhalter.
Lauritzen's actually one of the-
most famous people in
graphical models theory,
so this kind of graphic representations
of causal structures.
Then I added, actually, this slide here.
So I was, I had long conversation
with my daughter today,
and tried to figure out
which movies to take here,
which somehow tried to violate this idea
of a directed acyclic graph.
So you have time-travels,
where you have loops between
the past and the future.
So there are people, and
in these movies, actually,
people try to justify, even, such loops,
physically.
And this-
this movie here, Groundhog Day,
was actually presented by
the Santa Fe Instituters,
many years ago, and it was
commented by Murray Gell-Mann,
who actually discovered the quarks,
and-
he was asked whether this
makes physical sense,
to-
the idea's to go to start again a new day,
every day to start again,
and try to improve.
So you go back, after, after
you spend the whole day,
you go back to the beginning of the day,
and try to improve your behavior,
and that the end of the
day, of these iterations,
you even become an
expert in piano-playing,
even if you are not an
expert in the beginning.
So you really have these loops,
and which allow you to improve, here.
And again, so it was actually-
stated by Gell-Mann, that-
this is, physically, a reasonable idea.
And the same with the other movies.
So, in this last movie here, Tenet,
they even tried to,
to build the whole story,
based on the second law of thermodynamics,
which was, as we have seen
in the last presentation,
is a basic argument,
on-
explaining the direction,
the direction of time.
Okay,
let me go to the second topic,
so now once we have the
causal structure here,
the causal network,
we can define how the mechanisms,
which are part of this network,
did generate-
the phenomena.
So how they generate
actually a distribution.
So, basically, it's a simple rule,
you start, you have a
numbering of the nodes,
which is compatible with that structure.
So here, the numbering is,
you start with U, then A, then B, then C,
and then you, basically,
apply the mechanisms,
according to this numbering.
So you choose u according to
the probability distribution,
phi of u.
So it doesn't have any parents, here.
Then you choose a,
so this, according to the
distribution of A, given U,
so this is a Markov kernel,
and then you iterate, okay?
So these are the mechanisms.
Note that I did not
use the letter P, here,
really in order to refer,
make a distinction between,
a mechanism, and the
probability distribution.
So the right-hand side is basically,
a combination of mechanisms,
and it describes how the
probability distribution,
that-
of the-
of joint events, on the full set.
So the distribution, the
probability of u, a, b, c,
is exactly given, in
terms of these mechanisms.
So-
I want to highlight here,
that the left-hand side is, basically,
describing the phenomenology,
and the right-hand side is
describing the mechanisms.
And this equation is giving you a rule,
how to generate the phenomenon,
based on the mechanisms.
Now we can ask the question:
"Once we know the phenomena,
the joint distribution,
can we actually infer the mechanisms,
based on these phenomena?"
And the answer is,
we can, we can try.
The way people try it,
is in the following way.
They take the distribution,
the joint distribution,
so this is the observed distribution,
and then,
you can actually test
condition-independent statements.
So, if this distribution
is generated by mechanisms
that are compatible with this graph,
then it has to satisfy this
condition-independents,
these two condition-independent
statements.
So U is independence,
stochastically independent
of B given A,
and C is independent of A,
given U and B.
So, these are the two
condition-independent statements,
that follow from this structure, here.
So if you take the joint
distribution and do these tests,
you will actually, you will
be able to verify this.
The question is, do we recover
the underlying structure
only by testing this,
and the answer is no, we don't,
because there are many more graphs,
directed acyclic graphs,
that satisfy the same set
of condition-independent statements, okay?
In this case, so that's this graph here,
but you can also change,
modify this graph a bit,
and it will give you the same set
of conditions-independent statements.
And this is actually
referred to as Markov-
equivalence.
So all three graphs would
be Markov equivalent,
in the sense that they will give you
the same condition-independent statements.
So, once you have generated,
with the mechanisms,
the joint distribution, so the phenomenon,
once you have reached the
phenomenological level,
you cannot go back to
the to the mechanisms,
simply by observing and testing
the condition-independent statements.
So, there is a-
a whole-
the theory is well-developed,
that describes, actually,
the equivalence, Markov
equivalence classes of graphs.
So it's a well-known theory.
I'm going to skip this,
and continue with section number three.
So the intention, of this,
the Markov-
my presentation of Markov equivalence
is to show you that just observing
the system is not enough.
You can observe,
but you will not be able to recover
the full underlying structure,
simply by observation.
So this is why Pearl actually introduces
the notion of intervention.
So you have to be able to
intervene into the system.
And this is a second kind of experiment,
so experimental operation, if you wish.
One experimental operation is observation,
and the second one we are
going to talk about now,
is intervention.
And I'm going to define intervention,
I have to refer to the previous-
presentation.
Intervention was also
mentioned several times,
especially when stating that the future
can be influenced through
intervention, but not the past.
So that was that, that
can actually be verified,
within this setting, here.
So, let me define intervention.
Let's say...
Let's assume that this is the,
the causal-
network.
So we have the directed acyclic graph,
and we have the mechanisms,
alpha, beta, gamma.
We want to intervene in A,
and then observe B.
So what does this mean?
So, intervention, in
A, means the following.
If we, if we consider the
full joint distribution,
according to the original
mechanisms, alpha beta and gamma,
it will be given,
according to this formula.
That's the formula that
I have just discussed.
So now,
you could observe
the conditional probability of B, given A,
that using standard probability theory,
but intervention means
something different.
Intervention means changing the mechanism.
So, in this product-structure here,
we have, in A, we have
the mechanism, alpha.
Alpha takes input from U,
and generates a distribution-
of small a's,
according to alpha. Okay?
That's the Markov kernel, sitting in A.
Now, if we intervene in A,
let's say we want to set the state of A,
to a hat.
Then, that means that we decouple...
Basically we change the mechanism of A,
by replacing it,
by alpha hat,
and alpha hat is simply
very special Markov kernel,
which is 1, it gives the distribution 1.
So the probability of a is one,
if a equals a hat, and zero, otherwise.
So this is nothing but saying that-
we set the state of A,
to a hat, that's it.
And in order to stay with my
previous formal description,
I need to define a Markov kernel,
and that's the way I do it, here.
Formally, it simply means
changing the mechanism
to a constant value,
a hat.
And now, instead of this
product structure here,
we have a new product structure,
so that's the-
we get a new causal-
network,
but now the mechanism in
A is changed to a hat,
ah, alpha hat, from alpha to alpha hat.
So phi remains the same,
beta remains the same,
gamma remains the same, and
alpha is replaced by alpha hat.
And that's it.
That's the post-interventional
distribution.
Now, let's-
consider,
so what I have shown to you here,
is the post-interventional
joint distribution,
after imposing a hat.
Now I want to marginalize out U, B and C,
just to know the post-intervention
distribution over B,
imposing A.
So that means,
so that's the thing we want to compute,
so, what do we see in
B if we impose a hat?
So that's basically marginalizing out
all the others, U and C.
So we take this
post-intervention distribution,
that I have derived previously,
and marginalize out,
and that has the product structure.
Then we can go through the calculation,
and you get p of b as the result,
of the intervention.
So that means that the-
effect of-
intervening in A,
is simply...
so if I intervene in A and
set the state to a hat,
I will observe B with the
original probability, p of b.
The important thing to
note, here, is that b,
that probability distribution
is not dependent on a hat.
So it's different from it.
This is really something
that you don't get,
with-
with classical conditioning.
So, with classical conditioning,
the condition probability of B,
given A, as shown here,
will be actually dependent on A.
But when you, intuitively
you will, you would not,
because there's no arrow here,
you would not expect any effect
in B, if you intervene in A,
because there is no path from A to B.
And this is exactly what you get here.
So as the result of intervention,
you get simply the distribution of B,
with no dependence on a hat.
So, this reflects our intuition
that there is no path,
from A to B, okay?
- [Priya] Hold on, we have,
I just had a quick question.
So we are still talking about
deterministic systems, right?
So,
that there isn't, when we
say there's no path between,
from A to B,
do you mean that there is a
very suppressed probability
for a path from A to B,
or there really is no path,
from A to B?
- [Nihat] There is no,
no path, from A to B.
So that's the assumption, here.
So the underlying, the structure of it,
is a directed acyclic graph,
and some of the edges
are simply not there.
So that means there's no causal-
if no possibility...
It's like the future-
cause, influencing the past.
- [Priya] Right.
- [Nihat] Intuitively, you would say
there is no possibility.
Even no low-probability.
Okay?
So simply...
- And that is independent
of whether the system
is classical or quantum?
Right, so is it...
- [Nihat] So the quantum
version of this is not,
is not well-developed.
So I'm, I was referring to quantum setting
in the context of a mechanism.
So, each of these factors here,
are Markov kernels,
and in the quantum setting,
this would be completely positive maps,
but the theory of causal networks
is not well developed in,
in the quantum setting.
But the notion of a mechanism is,
has an analog in the quantum setting.
- [Priya] Okay, thank you.
- [Nihat] You are welcome.
So-
yeah, so we have the
post-intervention distribution here,
and it really is different
from the usual conditioning,
p of b, given-
observing a hat.
But now let's do the same
thing, now intervening in U,
and observing C.
So we can do the same calculation here,
a similar calculation.
So P of C, imposing u hat,
and if you go through it,
this time, it turns out,
that it's the same
post-interventional distribution
that you get if you condition
according to the classical
conditional distribution.
So that's the classical version of it
would be p of c comma u hat,
divided by p of u hat.
That's the classical version of it.
And we have seen here,
that it's not the same,
but in this case, it is the same.
So the do operator,
the intervention operator,
is exactly the same in this example,
as the classical conditioning operator.
Okay?
And that has a reason, actually.
So you can sometimes,
as we see, sometimes,
the intervention
gives you the
post-interventional distribution,
is the same as the...
Interventional conditioning
is the same as classical conditioning,
and sometimes it's not.
And let me just summarize, here.
So how we,
what we just did,
or maybe I can just skip this,
so there is a general-
general formula for-
for computing the
post-intervention distribution,
but I'll skip this.
So here's the answer,
when the intervention,
interventional conditioning
gives you the same as the
observational conditioning.
So the do means, we intervene in A,
and observe B,
and that's the distribution over-
over-
B,
imposing in A,
and that's the conditional distribution.
And they are the same, if, and only if,
there is-
B is-
so they are the same, if
B is not a cause of A,
and there is no common cause of A and B,
and you can read it out structurally.
So for example, if we look at A and B,
so there- B is not the cause of A,
because there is no path from B to A,
so that's satisfied,
and there's no common cause of A and B.
So there is no-
node pointing to A and B.
So, if we revert this direction,
then there would be a common cause here.
So if this is satisfied, so
this condition is satisfied,
then the interventional
conditioning is the same
as the observation conditioning.
But, if we look at C and B,
there is a common cause of-
I'm sorry, C,
yeah.
B and C, yeah, B and C.
So C is not the cause of B,
so the first requirement is met,
but there is a common cause of B and C.
It's this one.
So we have U, which is
with a directed path,
from U to B,
and the directed path from U to C.
So there's a common cause of B and C,
and in that case,
we cannot expect the intervention
to be the same as observation.
Okay? And the same with this case,
the causal effect of A on C,
we have a common cause on A and C,
So again, we don't have equality.
So this characterizes
exactly the situations
where intervention
differs from observation.
But intervention gives us more.
And now comes-
now comes a really important thing that-
notion, the notion of
identifiability of causal effects.
So,
let me motivate this a little bit.
We know intervention gives
us more, some information,
sometimes more information
than just observing the system.
This is what I tried to-
to demonstrate here.
But often, I mean, if we
know all the mechanisms,
I have shown you the formula
for the intervention,
you could simply compute the
post-intervention distribution,
but that's, that doesn't help as much,
because we do the intervention
in order to get the mechanisms,
so that's the chicken/egg problem, okay?
So we don't know all the mechanisms,
so that we can actually-
compute the post-intervention
distributions.
So, on the other hand, in experiments,
so in experimental intervention setting,
we take a system, a natural system,
and we do intervene into
the system, experimentally.
So we don't do the computation,
so what will happen,
but we simply test it.
So we do the intervention,
and observe the system,
and see if there's any effect.
So that's the experimental intervention.
But this, of course, we cannot do all...
I mean, sometimes there
are ethical problems,
you cannot intervene into
the brain of a person,
that's simply not possible, okay.
So this is like a...
You know that you can get more
information out of the system
if you intervened experimentally,
but sometimes it's simply not possible.
So the question now, and
the deep question, is,
can we predict the
outcome of intervention,
even without actually
intervening into the system,
simply by observing it?
And that's the question
of identifiability of causal effects.
The answer is sometimes we can,
and here's an example,
I have two examples.
So one is actually-
I refer to it as the backdoor example,
and the next one will be
the front-door example.
These are typical examples,
which you can study in Pearl's book.
So if you intervene in B, and observe C,
so we do the same calculation
that we did before.
The marginalization steps,
then you have the joint distribution,
and the joint distribution
you can replace by the mechanisms,
and then do the calculation here,
and then you end up
with this formula here.
And the nice thing about
it, is the following:
on the left-hand side,
you have the do operation,
so, which basically says
if you intervene in B,
you will, if you did this, if
you do this experimentally,
you will observe this distribution on c.
But if you don't do it experimentally,
you can simply go
through this calculation,
and read out this equa...
this-
expression here.
So this expression can
be completely computed,
based on the joint
distribution of A, B and C.
So this is simply p of a comma b comma c,
divided by p of a comma b,
and this is p of a, so
that's all computable,
by simply observing the joint
distribution, A, B and C.
And that's,
somewhat confusing, but-
yeah, so it basically
suggests that you can replace
the actual intervention here,
by-
observation,
by the information that you get,
in terms of observing the system,
but you have to change,
somehow, the formula.
So it's not just p of c given
b in the classical setting,
so that would, if you condition a here,
if you write p of a,
given-
b,
here,
instead of p of a,
then you will end up with p of c,
given b, in the classical way.
But this formula is, so to say,
different from the classical formula,
but it, this equation tells you
that you can actually predict
the post-interventional distribution,
based on observations.
So, in this setting, and
the terminology of Pearl,
we can say that the causal effect
of b on c,
is identifiable by the joint
distribution, A, B, and C.
Okay?
So we don't really
intervene to the system,
we simply observe,
and then we can compute
what what would happen,
if we intervened into the system.
So that's the philosophical-
thought, here.
So,
for example, we can
use it in this setting,
so I tried to draw a large network here,
so it's of course not huge,
but it's-
enough to demonstrate the point, here.
So, if you have such a network,
and you want to intervene
in V, and observe w,
okay, so what is the
causal effect of V on w?
So you could, of course, if
you knew all the mechanisms,
you could compute this,
as I have demonstrated,
but this we don't have.
So the question is...
And if you just observe the
joint distribution of V and w,
you can compute the
conditional distribution of V,
of w given V.
But the, the backdoor criterion
tells us, so this formula,
tells us that we can actually compute
what would happen,
in w,
if we intervened in V,
by just observing V, w,
and, in addition to that,
the parents of V.
So you see it,
so the inter-
the causal effect
of the post-intervention
distribution on w,
imposing xv,
on the left-hand side,
so that's an interventional concept,
can be written as something
which is computable,
based on observations only.
So, by observing v, w
and the parents of v,
no matter what the
surrounding is of the system,
and how huge it is, it doesn't matter.
You only need the joint distribution
of v, w, and the parents,
and then you will be able
to predict the outcome
of intervention, without intervening.
So, in other words, if you take the brain,
and you can, you could, if
you knew the parents of each,
of a particular neuron,
you could actually predict
the effect of that neuron
on some other region in the brain,
simply based on this joint distribution.
So there's a question.
- [Kyle] Hi, Nihat, this is Kyle Cranmer,
I just wanted to kind of, you know,
check or clarify that-
the part on the left,
where you actually make the intervention,
of course you could do
that experimentally,
and then just see what happens.
The part on the right is
the result that you get,
but that's assuming that the,
the causal diagram, right,
I just wanted to kind of...
'Cause the language you're
using kind of sounds like
you could avoid doing the intervention,
and you can just compute it
from the joint distribution.
- [Nihat] Yeah.
- [Kyle] But then, I think
(stammering)
- [Nihat] Yeah, yeah,
so that's (indistinct)...
- [Kyle] That's the case
where I assume you're making
that assumption, right?
- [Nihat] Yeah, so
that's a very good point,
I'm actually not...
That's partly true, and it's
actually a very good point.
So some-
so you could think,
that, in order to make this,
to to have this equation,
you need to assume,
so to say, to know the
structure of the underlying,
the underlying structure of the network.
The point I'm want to make here,
is that we don't need that, actually.
No matter how the surrounding network is,
you don't need any information about this.
The only information that you need,
but that might be even too much,
is what are the parents of v?
So, only knowing the joint distribution-
so, you do need to know the parents of v,
so, which is, in this case, just i and j.
In the setting of, of neurons, of course,
you have like 1,000 or 10,000 neurons,
connected to one particular neuron.
So you would have to
record all the parents,
but-
the brain is, of course, much more.
So, the point I want to make
is that local information,
related to V, is enough,
in order to predict the
outcome of intervention,
in v,
with respect to w,
no matter what structure is around that-
that triple here,
so that you don't need more information.
You need some part of it, that's
I think the benefit of it.
- [Kyle] I know, I agree.
- So it's really
a full-
it's really a full chicken/egg problem,
if you would assume to
know the whole network,
but the main point here,
is that you don't need to
know the whole network,
but you do need to know
something about the network.
Does that answer
your question?
- [Kyle] Did you call this
conditional... Yeah, I agree (indistinct)
And this conditional, on the right,
would you consider that local information?
It seems like, in the picture, you know,
w and v are quite distinct.
But I agree, it's certainly
not knowing the whole network.
It's a,
it's a much smaller amount of information,
than you can...
- Yeah. That's much smaller.
So of course, in my drawing,
I wanted to highlight how small it is,
so I have just two parents here,
two nodes as parents,
but-
sometimes it is feasible.
You could record from the
parents, and the node itself.
So you have to record
from the parents of E,
and so this is the joint
distribution that you need, here.
And if you don't have access to that,
there's no way to compute it.
Okay. But it's much, much less
than knowing the full joint distribution.
- [Kyle] Great. Thank you.
- You are welcome.
So that's-
one thing,
that's the backdoor criterion,
and the front-door criterion
is somewhat surprising.
More surprising,
if you had this network here, let's say.
So the way I think about it is,
so I have, let's say these are
like intrinsic observations,
of a system, intrinsic
variables of system,
and then do you have U as the
huge environment, let's say.
So it's acting on A and C,
so this is a common cause of A and C,
and it seems that there is no
way to actually compute the-
to predict the effect of intervention
in A on C,
without having the full information here.
So let's say an agent is really restricted
to observing A, B and C,
and then it's affected by U,
and the only requirement
that you have here,
is that this intermediate variable
is not affected by the environment.
So just A and C.
But the way it's set up here, is-
to actually demonstrate
that it could be quite counter-intuitive.
So, in this case,
I wouldn't expect to be able to compute
the effect of intervention in A, and on C,
(stammering)
based on just observing A, B and C.
But, it turns out,
that if you go through the computation,
it's...
Here's a trick, you have to-
you have to use some
condition-independent statements here,
but then you end up with something.
So the interesting part is, this,
so you start with something
that takes into account
the mechanism of U.
This huge environment, let's say,
or surrounding world,
you have this mechanism
that has this, u, u, u,
everywhere, and suddenly,
in this last line,
u cancels out, and there is no u anymore.
And this simply just uses
condition-independent statements
that are compatible,
follow from this causal structure, here.
So this says that if you observe,
just A, B and C,
let's call them intrinsic variables,
you can predict the effect of,
of intervention in A on C,
without actually
intervening into the system.
And that's, to me, it's quite surprising.
It's more surprising
than even the, the front,
the backdoor criteria.
Just as a-
as an application,
so we did apply this to,
in the robotics context,
so coming back to maybe one comment here,
I started with directed acyclic graphs,
often, of course, like in neural networks,
or in agents interacting with the world,
we have cycles,
but the way we interpret them,
that is-
by unfolding them in time,
so you get this directed acyclic graph,
which represents the world,
and the brain of the agent
interacting with the world,
through sensing and acting, okay?
We actually simulate this kind of a-
of a sensory motor-loop,
in the context of agents that you create,
within the setting of virtual robotics.
So this is a-
kind of a creature that
we, for example, analyze.
Then interesting question would be here,
and that relates also
to the previous talk,
to the notion of agency.
So what is, what is the,
we could ask, what is the cause
and effect of the actions?
So this basically
summarizes the whole past,
the history to one variable age,
and reduces,
so to say,
the whole sensory,
the whole causal diagram
of the sensory motor-loop,
to this small, simpler one.
So now you can ask, what
is the causal effect of A
on the next of the actions
of the next sensory input?
And when we started this,
I was...
And we thought, okay, we have
this mechanism of the world,
which is, even in a
simulation like this, it,
you cannot deal with it,
It has too many states, you don't...
And that's basically
what the physics engine,
alpha is basically implemented
within this physics engine,
and then you have the sensors,
so there's no way to compute it
by incorporating alpha and beta.
But then we realized,
actually we don't need that.
So, if you'll study it carefully,
the causal effect of the
actions on the sensors,
is identifiable,
intrinsically by the agent,
by just measuring
the joint distribution
of its brain-state, C,
it's activator states A,
and the next sensor-states.
So the left-hand side is
interventional in nature,
and the right hand side is observational.
And that's simply by
the backdoor criterion.
And you can actually use
the front-door criterion
to compute the causal effect of your brain
on the next sensor-state.
Again, we have an
interventional thing here,
interventional-
a notion on the left-hand side,
and observational notion here.
So we could let the robot simply-
run, and do something,
and it will record a joint distribution,
and then predict its causal effects
on the next sensor-input.
So,
the shortcoming here,
and I want to highlight this,
all these equations are
based on the assumption
that the probability distributions
are strictly positive.
Pearl is assuming this,
and identifiability of cause and effects
always starts with this assumption.
In robotic settings, we have
a functional dependencies,
and this-
this assumption is not met.
This is why we are actually
working on generalizations
of this kind of identifiability.
So that's just one application.
Let me come, maybe...
So how much time do I have?
Left?
- [Priya] You could go for
another 5 to 10 minutes,
if you wanted to
- [Nihat] Okay.
- and wrap up.
- Let me highlight the
Common Cause Principle,
because I think this is
really, really important.
So, we have seen that
observation is not enough,
so we have to intervene sometimes,
in order to get the
structure out of the system.
And then, if we cannot intervene,
we can actually identify, sometimes,
the causal effect, even
without actual intervention,
by so-called virtual intervention,
replacing the intervention by observation.
But that, as pointed out correctly,
that requires some additional information
about the underlying structure.
Like knowing the parents, for example.
You don't have to know everything,
but you have to know something.
And, sometimes, you even don't know that.
So you know, don't know anything.
This is why I got interested
in the common cause principle.
Even without knowing anything,
you can say something about the
underlying causal structure,
and that brings me to the-
to the common cause principle.
Let me first introduce what,
how we model,
how we quantify stochastic dependence.
So, basically,
I really like this
information-geometry quantification.
Stochastic dependence, basically,
compares a joint
distribution, of variables,
from the product of the marginals.
Okay. And you have independence,
if this equals this, here.
So if you have equality,
this is a 1,
so this becomes 1, and
logarithm of 1 is 0,
so the whole thing becomes 0.
So, basically,
a stochastic dependence is the
distance from independence,
and by distance, I mean
the (indistinct) distance
or (indistinct) divergence,
which is this quantity here.
So, and here is a visualization.
So this manifold here,
this surface,
is basically denoting the
set of all distributions
that have product structure,
and,
dependence is simp-
dependence of a joint distribution p,
in a joint distribution p,
is quantified as distance
from independence.
And this distance is referred
to as multi-information,
and in this case, where
you have two variables,
so n equals 2, it's simply
the mutual information.
So that's a nice geometric interpretation
of stochastic dependence.
Now I want to present
a quite strong theorem,
that we derived, but for that,
I need to introduce the
notion of a common cause.
Let's say we have a network,
and we have observed
variables, here denoted by,
in green, here, highlighted in green.
So these are the observed variables,
and we have some surrounding,
causal network.
And, Ac-
denotes-
the-
set of elements, in the network,
in the full network,
that reach, at least,
C-observed variables.
Okay?
For example, A2,
is this, so this is denoted by red dots,
here, red nodes.
So all the red ones, reach at least two-
observed variables.
For example, this one reaches this,
and this.
Okay?
This one is reached,
reaches also 2,
it reaches this observed one,
but it also reaches itself,
by a path of length 0.
That's an important point here.
We refer to this as the
set of common ancestors.
So that's this, A stands for ancestors,
and the important point here is,
that when you observe
the joint distribution,
so you have n observed variables,
and-
you, basically,
quantify,
there correlation in this way.
H denotes the entropy.
So you take the sum of marginal entropies,
and subtract C times-
the joint entropy.
For C=1, it's simply this,
this quantity here.
For C=1, it is simply
the multi-information.
So, that will be greater than
or equal to 0 anyway, for C=1.
But,
so the theorem that we could,
that we could...
Actually, the inequality
that we could prove,
is the following.
You can upper-bound,
ah, lower bound the entropy
of the common ancestors,
of degree C+1,
by this quantity here,
quantity of correlation, only
of the observed variables.
So, again,
the right-hand side is
something that can be computed,
based on the observed variables.
The left-hand side really requires
the full surrounding network,
and it's the entropy of
the common ancestors.
So, which means that if
you observe n variables,
that you quantif...
You evaluate this quantity,
and it it turns out to be positive,
then you can infer-
that there is at least
one common ancestor,
of at least C+1 observed variables.
So you can infer the existence
of common ancestors of observed variables,
because, otherwise,
it's not possible to explain
the correlation of the observed variables.
Here's an example,
the famous Reichenbach's
common cause principle.
If you just plug in C=1, here,
it tells you, basically,
that's a corollary of
this general theorem,
if two observed variables are dependent,
then, so these are the two variables,
then there must be a path from 1 to 2,
a path from 2 to 1,
or there must be a common
cause, of both of them.
So that's a simple implication
of the more general theorem that we have.
Here's another example.
If you have variables-
that are completely correlate,
maximally correlated,
then, you cannot explai-
then there must be a common
cause of all of them.
So that's the implication.
So, this kind of correlation,
complete correlation,
can only be achieved by a common cause,
or common ancestor, that
reaches all observed nodes.
This already excludes, for example,
if you compare these networks,
you can say this is possible,
because this reaches all of them,
and here, it's also reached this one.
This is also possible,
but these two are not possible.
So you could exclude potential
explanations of the data,
simply based on the
correlation-structure of the nodes.
And here again, by this kind of test,
you-
if you compare the sum of
of the Shannon entropies
with the global Shannon entropy,
then this doesn't tell you anything,
so all three cases are possible.
If this is,
the left-hand side is greater
than the right-hand side,
then only case 1 and 2 is possible,
and if even the margin,
the sum of the marginal entropies
is greater than 2 times the joint entropy,
then you can say, this
cannot be explained,
by this or this test, to be this one.
That's the-
the strength of this theorem.
I'm...
Maybe one final remark,
I'm not going to talk
about knock-outs anymore,
but just to-
refer to this inequit...
So we continued studying this result,
which I'm really proud of.
So it has been published,
it has been derived by my
former student, Bastian Steudel,
based on my previous work,
and we could show, in this paper,
that it's a sharp bound,
so it cannot get better.
That's-
highlighted in this paper,
but in a more recent paper,
we could show that,
in most-
generically...
So when you sample networks, so to say,
according to Jeffreys prior,
then most networks will not be,
will not allow you to infer common causes.
So it is sharp,
in the sense that there
exist situations where you,
where you reach this upper bound,
where you have equality
instead of inequality.
But, these regions where you have this,
are very tiny, in the space of
all possible causal networks.
So that's the downside of it.
And,
yeah, I think I'll stop here,
and if there's interest,
maybe tomorrow I could say more
about knockout interventions.
But let me, let me stop here,
due to the time constraints.
- Thank you so much, Nihat.
This was very, very intriguing.
I have a lot of questions myself,
so I would just go ahead
and start with one,
and share the floor with everyone else.
So I think, I really think this,
the last set of ideas,
the common cause
principle that you showed,
is really, really powerful.
And that is what I can see as something
that I can actually apply,
when I'm thinking about
the kinds of systems
that I'm looking at.
But, you know, I wonder,
what happens if we have
incomplete information,
on the maximally correlated variable.
So, you know, there are X1 to Xn,
that are, in fact, maximally correlated,
but we only know about, say,
n-1 of them, or n-2 of them,
then how do we work things out?
Because, that is often
the case in astrophysics.
So, one of the problems we have,
is we don't actually know if we...
When we make observations,
and you see two quantities
that are correlated with each other,
what we don't know, is whether
this is a mere projection,
of a higher dimensional correlation,
between larger number of variables,
or it is actually just a
true contained correlation,
only between these two variables.
- Yes, so, that's a very good question.
So this theorem does not
require completeness,
so it's really, so you observe...
So, you know, it's not complete.
So there's this huge world outside,
and you are observing n variables.
So n could be n-1,
you have the joint distribution
of these n-1 variables,
and you consider the-
correlation structure
of the n-1 variables,
and you can infer common
ancestors, or common causes,
of these n-1 variables.
Okay? So that's a...
It's not required that you know-
the only requirement here,
is that you assume that your physics-
the system that you-
the underlying observation,
can be described in terms
of a causal network.
That's the underlying assumption, here.
If it can't, then you can't
use this inequality, here,
to infer common causes.
- [Priya] I see.
- But this also relates to-
to another question that...
So of course you could take,
if you have the marginal
distribution of n variables,
you could consider all
marginals of these n variables,
and you could compute these
quantities that we have,
therefore the marginals,
and you could try to get
out more information,
about the underlying network,
in a large, a larger network,
and it's not clear to me,
I think you can get out more information
than just considering the
quantity for the n variables.
- [Priya] Right. And similarly, if I,
if the correlation structure,
assuming, as you said,
that it's valid,
and you can represent
it by a causal network.
So suppose there are,
in fact, n variables,
but that I have access only
to a sparser sub-sample.
- Yeah, that's a very good question.
So throughout my-
my whole presentation,
I did not address the issue of-
statistics.
So, that's of course, a deep problem,
and a deep, deep question, how to...
So all I did, is, starting
with the joint distribution,
assuming that we know
the joint distribution,
clearly, if we don't,
if you only have data,
like the empirical distribution,
generated by the mechanisms,
we have first to,
to infer-
the joint distribution,
and then apply this inequality.
So,
that's something that I haven't-
worked on yet,
but it's a very important problem.
So, basically, inferring common causes,
based on empirical data distributions.
That would be the, core problem.
And of course, associated with it,
generalization-
aspects, like statistical
learning theory, and so on.
- And then one final question, which is...
And in, in these causal networks,
are you making the assumption
that you know the mechanism already?
That you have
- [Nihat] No.
- prior information,
or is the mechanism that you
are going to infer, right,
is the details of the mechanism
that are part of the inference.
I wanna know where the mechanism sits,
in this sort of landscape.
- Yeah, so you basically, it's a bottom...
So I started the whole thing by,
in a kind of bottom-up approach,
so starting with the-
with the basic components.
So you have the structure,
the directed acyclic graph,
and then each node, to
start with the mechanism,
which is a Markov kernel.
And then the question is, the-
what are the interesting
top-down problems?
So you have the observations,
and what are the questions
that you would ask?
And one question that you could ask,
what is the underlying structure,
or what is the mechanism, and so on.
And in order to get them,
I don't assume to know them,
I only assume that they exist,
and then I could aim to reveal them,
through observation, or
through intervention,
and this is definitely possible
in terms of intervention.
- Right? So I think
this is the other thing
that I wanted a slight clarity on,
the, sort of, differentiation
between an observation,
and an intervention.
- Mhmn?
- [Priya] What I mean, is,
so if you can use the sensory
motor example that you had,
of that little crawling creature,
so-
how would you separate?
I'm trying to map it
onto problems in physics,
so I'm trying, because you
know, their observation,
and intervention, have very
particular definitions,
and I'm trying to see if they
map onto the same definitions.
So the intervention would
be, something like, you know,
if you perform a controlled experiment.
- Mhmn.
- It would be a repetition,
for example, right, would be,
would that be an intervention,
or would that be an observation?
I'm a little confused
about the separation,
between what is an observation,
and what's an intervention.
- So basically if you refer to this agent,
perceiving and acting in a world,
so it's doing something, it's functioning,
and-
an intervention would
require, actually, to set...
For example, if you
want to quantify the co-
to get the causal effect,
of its brain, on it's next sensor-input.
By definition, it would
require somebody from outside,
setting its brain to one state.
- [Priya] Right.
- And then observing
the next sensory input.
So like something from outside,
but that's, of course,
a thought experiment.
The question is, that you cannot do,
but then the question is,
is it possible to get the same results,
so the effect of the brain-state
on the next sensory input,
based on just observing the system,
without any intervention from outside.
And this is the message, is
yes, it is it's possible.
- Ah, okay.
- But then you have to change the formula,
So it's very simple, I
mean, it's very simple.
The question is, whether
you can apply this.
Maybe I can share this slide here.
Yeah, so, this is for example.
So that would be the
somebody from outside,
- [Priya] I see.
- [Nihat] controlling the actions,
- Right.
- And then observing
the outcome on,
on the sensors.
So, and that would be the left-hand side,
but you can forget about this,
if you can measure the joint
distribution of C, A and S,
by replacing this, so you can remove,
get rid of the external-
intervener, so to say,
external agent,
by just using the formula
on the right-hand side.
And, if you want to compare this,
with the classical conditioning,
you would have to...
So if you just replaced p of c,
by p of c,
given a.
- [Priya] Mhmn.
- p of c, given a,
then, you get exactly p of s,
given a,
without the do operator,
simply by the usual formula
for conditional probabilities.
- [Priya] Right.
- So it's almost,
almost the same, but there's
one important difference here,
this conditioning here.
So, if you remove that conditioning on a,
you get exactly the
post-intervention distribution,
but that has,
it's not,
yeah, it's not clear that
you can actually apply this,
because this requires
counterfactual situations,
so that you actually can compute
the conditional distribution,
in-
situations,
where...
So this has to be defined,
in other words.
- Yeah, I was just gonna say,
that needs definition, right?
Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
So that,
that has to be defined,
and of course, if the
probability of C, A is 0,
you don't know what this is.
- [Priya] I see, yeah.
- And then the,
this equality breaks down.
So that's the downside of it.
So, it is a nice-
conceptual thought,
and it might be applicable
in some settings,
in our settings setting,
we did not,
we did apply it, but we did
not get very far with it,
because of this counterfactuals here.
So,
one has to extend the
identifiability problem,
to situations,
with a zero probab-
with-
to situations where the distribution
is not strictly positive.
- [Priya] Okay.
Great. So I want to invite Mark Gerstein,
who is a bioinformatics
expert, to ask his question?
- [Mark] Hi. Sure, I had a question,
I think it was on your slide,
on the identifiability of causal effects.
I think that was where
we had another question,
and you know, this...
I was just curious,
could you just,
to get some intuition about
the formula you have there,
can you just explain what happened
in the kind of complicated network?
If, say, there was only
one path between V and w,
or if there was no paths between V and w,
just, you know, just to get some intuition
how that formula would
be affected by that.
- So-
so if you just as one example,
because all arrows go
from V to w, here, right?
So there's no path from w to V.
- [Mark] (stammering)
There's many paths, now,
I think it's related to the
question you got earlier.
So there's many paths now,
that you can kind of track,
they're indirect from V to w, right?
You can just-
- [Nihat] Mhmn.
- [Mark] What if there was no paths,
you could not follow the
direct, and there was no paths,
or there was just one single path.
What, what would that do to your-
how would that manifest
itself in your equation?
- So if there's-
no path,
then the outcome of this will be simply P-
of X-
w,
without any conditioning, here,
because,
if there is no path, then the outcome of w
will not depend on any intervention here,
because there's no path.
So, no matter what kind of w,
of state you have in,
in V,
this will not have any influence on w.
- [Mark] Okay, sure.
- So that will be p of xv.
And that's something,
that's something reasonable.
If there is one path,
there will be no, no difference,
no special-
change of this formula.
And it will not, it will not,
it will not simplify.
Maybe, it's easier to,
it will be easier to
prove this equality here,
if you had only one path.
If you write it down with one path,
you will be able to prove this equality,
maybe more easily.
- [Mark] Okay, okay.
- Great.
Thanks.
I think there is another
question, now from Agasti Arana,
and his question is, "Could
you provide some intuition as
to why the identifiability
of causal effects here,
only depends on the parents of V,
and not on all of the ancestors.
Yes. It's an excellent question.
That I was also curious about.
(electronic chiming)
- It, the thing-
the reason for that,
is that you have conditioned
independent statements.
So the-
basically in any,
directed acyclic graph,
so in any Bayesian network,
the node is independent
of its non-descendants,
in particular, independent
of its ancestors,
given its direct causes,
which are the parents.
So you have always, for each node,
each node is independent
of its non-descendants,
given its direct causes.
And-
that's their so-called local-
Markov property,
which basically means,
if you know your parents,
the state of your parents,
you don't need to know more.
Any additional information
about your ancestors,
or even non-descendants,
will not help you to to predict any-
will not improve your predictions.
- Right. So you're just,
it's sufficient to go just one layer deep,
in (indistinct).
- Exactly.
That will be the,
the main reason for that.
- So, I guess I'll wait to see
if there are any other questions.
Meanwhile, I have one.
So, I was curious about-
what about the structure
of a causal network,
predicates predictability?
Like, you can predict, like, outcomes of,
say, time evolution-
if I'm looking at a system,
and I want to understand
the time evolution,
and if I assume that I
can actually model it,
as a causal network,
and that it satisfies
(electronic chiming)
all these conditions that we've
just all been talking about,
then is it maximally predictable?
Can you then make predictions?
How does predictability of
future states of the system,
assuming you can figure out
the mechanism, and so on.
Right? So is that connected to...
- Not really.
I mean, there is...
So the thing is, that the causal network,
is really coupled with
conditional independence.
So, the structure is,
so there's a one-to-one correspondence
between the structure, the graph,
and condition-independent statements.
And, in the context of a
dynamical system, for example,
you can, if you represent it in this way,
you can say
the future is conditionally
independent of the past,
given the present, okay?
This is something that you can say.
Condition predictability, is, I think,
more about dependence as
opposed to independence.
So, being independent or
conditionally independent,
does not mean that the
mutual information is high.
So the mutual information
between the past,
let's stick with this example,
the past and the future,
can be...
So the amount of information
that you can extract from the past,
in order to predict
the future, can be low,
even though...
So that's an additional requirement.
So, it's independent of the assumption
that the past and the future
are conditionally independent,
given the present.
So you can keep this,
this condition-independent statements,
past and future being
conditionally independent,
given the present,
and tune the predictability up,
by increasing the mutual information,
and tune it down,
- Round, with (indistinct)
- For example, in an IID setting,
you do have condition independence,
but there is no predictability at all.
So the mutual information is 0.
- [Priya] Right?
- Yeah.
- (indistinct)
you can,
so then it is tuned by the
amount of mutual information.
The predictability.
- Exactly, exactly, exactly.
That will depend of
course, on the mechanisms.
- [Priya] Right.
- Yeah.
- Great. Let me just quickly check,
if there are any more questions,
doesn't look like there are
any typed into the chat.
So I wanna take this
opportunity to remind everyone
that we'll have a more detailed
conversation and discussion
of the concepts that were
discussed in today's talk,
tomorrow at the same time, at 3:00 pm,
and the conversation will
be where between Nihat,
and Kyle Cranmer,
and we are really looking forward to it.
And Nihat, thank you so much
for your talk this evening,
and look forward to seeing you tomorrow.
- Thank you very much.
- Sorry about
the time difference,
so it's kind of a late,
late time for you in Germany,
right?
- That's, that's okay.
Thank you very much.
- Okay, thank you, bye-bye.
- [Nihat] See you tomorrow.
- Yeah. See you all tomorrow.
Bye everyone, thank you,
- [Nihat] Bye.
- and see you tomorrow.